c'est ici à la mosquée d'elancourt
qu'une quarantaine de fidèles se
réunissent tous les soirs du ramadan la
rupture du jeûne
appelé aussi l'iftar se fait au coucher
du soleil suivie d'une prière
depuis deux ans la mosquée invite
également différentes personnalités
politiques à venir échanger autour de
l'islam ne voulait pas pratiquer un
islam refermé sur lui-même
l'islam fait partie de la société
française est trop de mes connaissances
ou de clichés son véhicule et est avant
tout c'est un mois de générosité de
partage donc c'est pour ça qu'on invite
tout le temps d'autres personnes aussi
des personnes d'autres confessions qui
seront invités ce soir à venir partager
ce moment de générosité de bien-être et
ce jeudi ils ont été nombreux à répondre
à cette invitation
le maire d'elancourt des représentants
de la communauté juive des officiers de
police mais aussi le député yvelinois
benoît hamon sont venus partager ce
repas et dont on voit bien manger c'est
une bonne raison et en plus je trouve
cette démarche vertueuse que deux voilà
de partager ces moments et 2
et comment on pourrait le faire avec
toutes les autres religions que ce soit
gilles ou catholique et donnant aux
travaux fait grand plaisir mais sur
iliad et il ya des règles et des valeurs
il ya ya ya des contraintes aussi franc
français pas n'importe quoi c'est un des
plus beaux pays au monde et bien sûr il
faut s'adapter aussi sa culture culture
française à eva la ccl l'objet de nos
discussions régulières qui se passe nous
invitions est en cours est plutôt un
modèle l'est/sud-est d'intégration et
rust
le ramadan mois sacré et quatrième
pilier de l'islam se terminera cette
année le 5 juillet